bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors on l'a vu
encore l'union européenne et le royaume
uni ont ne sont pas sur la même longueur
d'onde on aurait pu penser le contraire
avec cette crise sanitaire international
que l'on vit mais moins qu'on puisse
dire que c'est que s'ils sont d'accord
sur une chose c'est qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord
en fait la réunion d'hier a été très
décevant ce c'était même un recul par
rapport à la réunion d'avril dernier sur
les sujets principaux que cas évoqué
michel barnier à l'instant là des
problèmes importants comme les relations
commerciales comme la pêche et rien n'a
bougé
vous avez cité le 1er juin qui est la
prochaine et dernière étape et j'ai peur
que cela vous disent pas vraiment
n'oubliez pas c'est fin juin qui est la
date limite à partir de laquelle les 27
pays européens ont dit aux anglais
vous pouvez demander un report d'un an
deux ans pour négocier sérieusement et
trouver un accord sur les goristes une
somme refuse toute prolongation
j'ai bien peur qu'on arrive dans un cul
de sac
à la fin du mois de juin et y la crise
sanitaire que j'évoquais elle ne change
en rien on a pu quand même penser que la
situation allait s'assouplir entre les
deux parties écoutez je pense plus belle
que c'est pillon je pense que la crise
du que vides arrange boris johnson on
sait très bien qu'avec le bridge site ça
allait mal se passer pour l'économie au
ps pour les entreprises anglaises pour
les citoyens anglais et grâce à la crise
du chaos qui règne dramatique aussi bien
en angleterre que dans le reste du monde
occidental
boris johnson doit pouvoir cacher les
catastrophes du break 6 pour
l'angleterre quart savez loyer au milieu
des autres graves problèmes économiques
en laquelle l'angleterre le royaume uni
et nous tous
nous allons être confrontés je crois que
ça arrange complètement monsieur boris
johnson alors lorsque michel barnier
parle des valeurs européennes et que son
homologue lui évoque une nouvelle
approche nécessaires de la part de
bruxelles que faut-il comprendre
écoutez il faut comprendre une chose
très simple la position de la france est
claire nous soutenons tous la position
de michel barnier et les valeurs
européennes et qu'il qualifiait l'union
ce qui nous a surpris vendredi c'est que
les anglais on ne remit une couche sur
certains sujets qui ne posait même pas
problème nous avons été choqués devant
les anglais parlé d'atteinte aux droits
des citoyens britanniques
je ne sais pas d'où ça vient c'est même
le contraire je pense que la réciprocité
qui est prévu entre la protection des
citoyens anglais d'un côté ou à l
inverse la protection de l'ensemble des
citoyens européens que ce soit ceux qui
habitent et travaillent en angleterre où
que ce soit ceux qui habitent et
travaillent dans les autres pays
européens
cette réciprocité est une garantie pour
tout le monde
qu'est-ce qui est venu faire cette
critique des anglais sur une menace qui
pèserait sur les droits des citoyens m a
dit qu très sincèrement j'ai
l'impression que c'est du grand
n'importe quoi
la prochaine session de négociations est
prévue le 1er juin on va dire sans
accord à votre avis comment la situation
peut-elle évoluer
écoutez sans accord moi je pense alors
c'est le jeu reste un peu optimiste je
pense que boris johnson peut encore
changer ou tout dernièrement ça fait
partie de sa stratégie
il ya la date fatah de fin juin jusqu'à
ce jour il peut encore dire je souhaite
avoir une progression incroyable de
négociations eh bien j'espère
sincèrement il profitera de ce délai
supplémentaire
il peut très bien arriver que la date du
2 juin que vous évoquez ce soit pas
mieux que ce qui s'est passé hier
vendredi entre les deux parties mais il
restera encore tout le mois de juin et
boris johnson est capable de jeu direct
joué un jeu
c'est un jeu à mon avis dangereux de
jusqu'au bout dire non je veux pas de
prolongation des négociations
ça fait tellement catastrophique aussi
bien des anglais
ça va être catastrophique pour
l'angleterre des comédies anglaises se
sera pas mieux pour les 27 pays
européens
merci beaucoup ladislas poniatowski cela
serait leur rapporteur de la commission
spéciale sur le break site merci à vous